welcome to science hangout from science
mission today we have dr. Charles Baron
a chair and professor of biochemistry
University of Iowa with us dr. Brenner
is an accomplished researcher who has
published more than 100 research
articles and won several awards dr.
Brenner
in 2016 one SBM be award for exemplary
contribution to education in 2015 he won
keynote lecturer at the Brown University
pathobiology retreat in 2015 he was the
Eckerson student lecture he gave the
Eckerson
student lecturer in biochemistry and
redox biology at the University of
Nebraska in 2014 dr. Brenner won the
state of Iowa Regents Award for faculty
excellence so there are many more Awards
which he won throughout his career so
let's welcome dr. Brenner
dinner welcome to science hangout thanks
it's great to be with you so let me
first congratulate you on your nature
communication paper which got published
this morning yes thank you and let's get
going so can you please talk about your
background education etc all right well
I like to say I'm a country boy with a
kind of a fancy education from outside
of Boston raised in New England and
graduate of New Milford High School in
New Milford Connecticut stayed in state
to go to Wesleyan University okay I
graduated with a degree in biology in
1983 around the time that the
biotechnology industry was getting going
around Boston around the San Francisco
Bay Area at that time it was called the
genetic engineering industry rather than
biotech and I went out to the San
Francisco Bay Area and I worked there
for about five years into biotech
conveyor
Vince was Chiron corporation hmm and the
other was DNA X Research Institute in
Palo Alto California and learned trains
in in East molecular biology and
genetics in industry and then I at that
point I knew how to do experiments and I
wanted to run I wanted to know how to
run a research group and I went off to
graduate school at Stanford and so
stayed in the in the San Francisco Bay
Area ten years I mean my biotech
experience and and my grad school
Stanford I worked with Bob fuller in the
biochemistry Department mm-hmm
and I purified an enzyme called qex to
protease which prohormone processing
enzyme and great experience learning to
do entomology with Bob and in the
biochemistry department at Stanford and
then 1993 moved back to the East Coast
and I trained an x-ray crystallography
with Gregg fresco and Detmar ringa at
Brandeis and 1996 I got my first faculty
position and though I had a faculty
position at Jefferson in Philadelphia
Thomas Jefferson University from 1996 to
2003 and was recruited to Dartmouth in
2003 where I was on the faculty of the
Norris cotton Cancer Center yeah well as
the department's of genetics and
biochemistry at Dartmouth mm-hmm I
expanded my program into any be
metabolism at Dartmouth okay and then
2009 I moved here to University of Iowa
okay so it's been a very great
experience working in a number of really
interesting environments okay and talk
us about your mentors or Road models who
helped you throughout your career
they've all been really really important
me so I I had a it was an undergraduate
research Brad Wesleyan with a guy named
Barry Kiefer corsola geneticist when I
was in industry I'd great supervisors
Tony brake who was a product of of UC
Berkeley he worked with Jeremy Thorne ER
at Berkeley and then at DNA X Research
Institute I worked with Cooney Matsumoto
who's a very accomplished East
geneticist he's now a C elegans
geneticist in Nagoya in Japan
Bob Fuller I mentioned my grad advisor
is one of the you know dearest people in
the world and and really smart guy a
wonderful role model for how to ask the
right questions and and do thoughtful
experiments and then I had the great
pleasure and opportunity to work for
Greg Petco and Dagmar ringa when I was a
postdoc at Brandeis and I were remain
close to all of those almost all of
those people
Barry Kiefer Kieffer's passed away and I
don't get to talk to
Sakuni Matsumoto very often but Bob
fuller and Greg Mexico I'll continue to
advise me and and I try to be available
to my former grad students and postdocs
in the same way okay and I know you had
a busy person with all the departmental
work and research and all those things
so talk to us about something about your
other vein research hobbies or interests
well that's a good right so work-life
balance yeah
so balance is is really important and
and so is the balance between energy
intake and energy
expenditure so I'd like to exercise okay
one of my new hobbies is yoga alas hot
yoga and doing vinyasa at you know 40
degrees C or something like that huh and
it's it's great to learn that I look
kind of like getting it to do things
where I'm a rank beginner I may not know
as much as other people in a in a
particular new area but I like the
sensation of noticeably improving from
one day to the next and so I very much
enjoy things like riding bicycle doing
aerobic physical activities hiking and
the new hobby is is yoga I also enjoy
gardening cooking following you don't
find those things I try okay okay so now
getting back to the lab like talk to us
about your lab black people grad student
postdocs how do you manage them what is
the experience well today is an exciting
day because it's as you said Nature
communications paper just came out when
it goes up on the website it'll be
called Trammell in C dot PDF meaning
it's Sam trammels third paper of 23rd
first off the paper 2016 so M Trammell
was our labs most recent PhD he's often
Copenhagen doing a postdoc wonderful
person trained in quantitative mass
spect and actually greatly improved our
methods for targeted nad metabolomic
sand he was involved in everything from
technology development to our first
published animal experiments which came
out earlier this year in which we showed
that nicotinamide rye beside is active
in preventing diabetic
to our first human clinical trial which
came out today we have we have more
postdocs in the lab at any given time
usually than grad students mm-hmm
right now I have poha an ear who's a fan
by whose postdoctoral research
scientists and Mark Schmidt who's also a
postdoctoral research scientist Marcus
is an expert in targeted metabolomics
and he actually right now he's mostly
doing targeted nad metabolomic s-- fan
by is a mitochondrial biochemist and
poke an ear is broadly interested in
metabolism weight management physiology
of boosting and evening metabolism rate
technician in the in the lab at Kiba
Chadha who supports all of our animal
experiments and for the last year my lab
has been having joint group meetings
with two other principal investigators
Murray me go from Queen's University
Belfast who's been on sabbatical with me
and she's actually moving on November
1st to University of South Alabama where
she she obtained a position as a full
professor and amy sandler Amy's an
assistant professor in health and human
physiology here at the University of
Iowa but her her lab spaces is located
essentially embedded in the biochemistry
department here at the University and so
we the three of our research groups meet
weekly and plan a lot of experiments
together so that we have the power of
organic chemistry and chemical biology
from the VGO group and Amy's interest in
vascular physiology and then my report
which is in nad vltava lummox
all aspects of boosting anyd metabolism
and really anything that relates to
anything we also have a project in our
group it relates to epigenetic control
of gene expression in which we're really
interested in how uncle G how wrasse
transformation and other outgo gene
changes lead to silencing of tumor
suppressor genes and I have doc named a
Shilpa Thakur who is the really the one
person in our group that is working on
how dnmt1 and tet1 are are dysregulated
by rats transformation okay and like I
know like you have published so many
good papers and all like but when you do
the experiments that is ups and downs
and all how do you motivate these kids
like when the experiments don't work
well you've got to have the right
disposition to to do science so you've
got to be patient and you've got to be
analytical self-critical aware of the
literature and you've got to communicate
so the people in my lab that do the best
example Peter belenki who's an assistant
professor at Brown University
in his about five years training as a
grad student at Dartmouth was more often
in my office two times a day than zero
times per day so you know grad students
are our adults and you know some want to
ask questions all the time and some sort
of don't want to ask as many questions
because they're I don't know maybe
they're afraid of asking what they
perceive as a dumb question as some sign
of something that they don't yet
understand but Peter and I just had a
great working relationship and he would
pop into my office at any time
throw an idea out or ask whether I knew
something about any new experiment that
he had in mind and its really through
that dialogue that we had a great
working relationship bet and he had a he
had a high batting average of
experiments that worked I think in large
part because we collaborated so well at
designing experiments and so I think
that people communicate well tend to do
the best experiments and so group
meeting is really important and open
sharing of ideas is really important and
interdisciplinarity is important and
that's kind of how my lab is benefitting
right now by having chemical biology
physiology and biochemistry metabolites
in the same group okay and you told us
about and now like which started working
about six years ago or so how did it
come about like like you had a kind of a
shift in like what yeah yeah well longer
ago than that we we published our first
paper on the discovery of the eukaryotic
nicotinamide ribose I'd kinase pathway
and cloning human nicotine my
driver-side kinase 1 and 2 that was 2004
so we were at Dartmouth it was shortly
after we moved from from Thomas
Jefferson University so I when I started
my lab in Billy about 20 years ago we
really had a molecular ecology focus and
we were very interested in tumor
suppressor genes work and I won't go
into the all of the twists and turns but
we we ran into an enzyme called
glutamine dependent nad synthetase yeast
Q&S one human Madsen one and I was just
quite interested as a biochemist and how
that enzyme works it has two active
sites that communicate with each other
and
but in early 2000s there was a re
candling of interest in nad metabolism
because nad
went from being a redox cofactor which
is incredibly important to not only a
redox cofactor but a consumed substrate
of a class of enzymes called sirtuins
and also poly adp-ribose polymerizes
parts cyclic adp-ribose synthetase is a
number of enzymes use nad but not as a
redox cofactor they use nad as a
consumed substrate and here I was having
cloned the gene for an nad bio synthetic
enzyme I was able to address whether we
understood the full range of ways in
which a cell can resynthesize nad from
component parts and it was in the course
of doing those experiments that we
discovered the nicotinamide Ryba side
kinase pathway when eating so we
discovered NR nicotinamide drive aside
as an additional nad precursor vitamin
this was published in cell in 2004
because it was rather surprising to
discover a new vitamin kind of so late
in the game the nad coenzyme had
basically been a thing in biochemistry
since around 1905 when arthur hardin
called it Kozai mase as a as a fraction
a non protein fraction that promoted
glycolysis or cell 3 fermentation and in
1938 conrad LVM discovered nicotinic
acid and nicotinamide niacin as as
vitamin b3 the commonly known precursors
of nad there was rather surprised that
there was still another vitamin for
cursor
of energy that was out there and and
that it took us until 2004 to uncover
and in the past what is it 12 years now
we've published almost 40 papers on any
D metabolism up until today which is the
first clinical trial of ten of my
driver-side so it's gone from being
literally something that was a plate a
say in which we detected nicotinamide
right aside in milk and identified the
human nicotinamide reverse side kinase
pathway in part by doing yeast so
literally we saw evidence of nicotine my
drive aside on a petri dish today we
report human clinical activity of
nicotinamide drive aside but the funny
thing is that as an over-the-counter
supplement nr is currently being used by
somewhere between a hundred and seventy
five thousand and two hundred thousand
people a day probably almost entirely in
the US so it's being used by almost one
out of a thousand Americans today as an
over-the-counter supplement well years
ago it was just a petri dish assay okay
pretty amazing projectory yeah let's
look at some of the work we are done in
published in Nature communications if
you could share the presentation sure
should we do you want some background
yeah right so I'll share presentation
with you let's see if this shares with
everyone can you see that
yep plastic so now the first thing I
have to do you know is I have to give a
disclosure because I have some you know
advisory activities with with industry
so chroma decks and can you see the
pointer as well yeah great so I'm on the
scientific advisory board of chroma
decks this is a company that is
commercialized and are I'm a co-founder
and chief science advisor of a company
called pro healthspan that that actually
sells NR to the public it's available at
protocol spam calm and and then I have
my own little business that is aiming to
do targeted metabolomics in order to
kind of figure out who needs and our
supplements and the effect of and our
supplements on on people so um just to
kind of give people an orientation on on
classically what nad is this is nad here
on the left and this is NADH here on the
right and so nad is a redox cofactor in
in biology and so when we're when we're
consuming macronutrients I mean carbs
fats protein
we're oxidizing fuels and nad becomes
reduced to NADH right and then NADH
becomes reoxidized to nad plus at the
mitochondrial inner membrane to make ATP
and then there are other processes in
which NADH which is reoxidized the
entity plus like like gluconeogenesis
and forming ketone bodies and you might
also know that there are related
compounds n ATP and NADPH which has the
phosphate here and the hydride here that
are important in in other classical
aspects of biochemistry so NADP for
making fossil ribose and RNA DNA the
Purser's NADPH for detoxifying three
radical species making steroid hormones
like testosterone and estrogen and then
right around the year 2000 Lenny grunty
and and several others showed that a
class of enzymes called sirtuins
have an nad requirement as well so now
I'm depicting
you look at the first way I depicted nad
there's a sorry there's a nicotinamide
moiety and then there's the rest of this
molecule this is ADP ribose now I'm
showing you ADP ribose linked to
nicotinamide and then an enzyme called
sirtuin let's see if I can do a close up
a little bit here zooming zoom window
okay so an enzyme called sir - or a
sirtuin will take an a peptide with it
an Isetta lated life seen like an Isetta
lated histone classically and it will
deacetylated lysine so that you have a
non modified peptide in the course of
doing that it uses nad and it breaks the
nav into two pieces a nicotine amide
moiety and an acetylene adp-ribose okay
it actually breaks and maybe and we're
interested in sir - because sir - is a
gene expression regulator in yeast the
two related enzymes regulate a lot of
protein functions in mammalian cells and
in humans and and in particular one of
the important functions of surtout and
yeast is that it's required for the
longevity benefit of calorie restriction
so calorie restriction can extend
lifespan and youth some other model
organisms and so there are genes that
respond to the level of glucose and the
level of other macronutrients is
required for the ability of low glucose
to extend lifespan and/or to requires
nad and so a lot of people thought gee
there must be some
aspect of any D metabolism that is
affected by the level of glucose and sir
- is a key regulator of that and so
people got interested in how nad is is
made incidentally sirtuins which are and
by the way you can read more about this
in this tips review sirtuins do this
reaction that I just depicted an Isetta
lated lysine deacetylated and that that
turns over nad and then arp burns over
na v in polymerizing ADP ribose and
synthetases cyclize here i've a co
moiety of nad so all of those things
consume a neighbor so so and and by the
way let me point out that when you have
DNA damaged poly adp-ribose polymerase
gets activated and degrades nad in
generating ATP ribose polymers and
that's involved in single strand DNA
repair and if you take a look at this
picture of an individual from a hundred
years ago that had a condition called
pellagra you notice that her son exposed
skin has these has this dermatitis
lesion right and so classically there
was a disease that we now understand was
an nad precursor deficiency mm-hmm cured
by improved diet and the discovery of
nicotinic acid and nicotinamide as
Milagro preventative compounds the her
sun exposed skin is damaged in part
because sun is activating PARP which is
the gray
and so there's not enough nad to do all
of the vital functions in cellular
metabolism that nad is involved in so
people through much of the 20th century
thought that nad is kind of a solved
problem because 1938 LVM discovered
these any deeper courser vitamins and
nad was involved in this redox biology
and so people thought it's not so
interesting any longer and then all of a
sudden in the year 2000
lynnie Goretti and others you know point
out that there are very important non
redox roles of nad many gets turned over
by enzymes like surtout that are really
important harp is really important
surtout is really important so people
thought gee let's let's figure out how
nad is made because probably there are
very important regulators of nad
metabolism that explain things like
longevity yep okay so I wonder if
anybody out in Google Hangouts land has
every ever watched a game of t-ball
mm-hmm watch t-ball yep watch t-ball
yeah yeah so this is the center fielder
okay in a t-ball game okay there's not a
lot of action in the outfield yeah right
most of the action is in the infield
because the ball ball doesn't usually
get out to the outfield and when the
ball finally goes out to the outfield
people get really really excited and
everybody the the left fielder and the
right fielder are coming in trying to
get it to fall this is me play center
field okay I won't say who's playing
left field in and right field
okay the ball came right to me okay
because I was working on this enzyme
glutamine
pendant nad synthetase and and and and
people looked at this chart this was
published by five different research
groups
it's everything that was known about any
DS synthesis has tryptophan coming in
from the left making any D there are
five enzymatic steps here
two more enzymatic steps and then nad is
made my favorite enzyme is here and then
sir two turns over nad two nicotinamide
and then nicotinamide is converted to
nicotinic acid nicotinic acid goes back
up here so according to this diagram
according to this diagram all roads to
nad went through my favorite enzyme no
okay
and when in the year 2000
it appeared that nad metabolism or any D
metabolites regulated sir - dr. grant a
suggested that NADH would be president
high concentrations at high glucose and
that NADH inhibits sir - and that what
calorie restriction would do this
calorie restriction would would lower
the level of NADH would will leave sir -
inhibition and then sir - would work
faster and the cell would have a more
youthful gene expression program so that
turns out that's not really true and
then an outstanding scientist at Harvard
David Sinclair invested that the sir to
product nicotinamide at its normal
cellular concentrations inhibited sir -
and that arise in an enzyme called PN C
1 which converts nicotinamide to
nicotinic acid that's the key to calorie
restriction so it's actually it is true
that high-dose nicotinamide inhibitor -
but the level of nicotinamide in in the
yeast cell doesn't actually inhibit sir
- okay and it's not really actionable
either so what we were working on was
really just how we were not trying to
explain longevity yeah
in 2004 we're just trying to understand
how this enzyme worked but what we
discovered is that at those steps that
were in black were not the only steps in
nad metabolism and we discovered and I
won't go through all of the many papers
but we discovered in blue the
nicotinamide right beside kinase pathway
this is pavel vegan offski who was the
postdoc in my group that found NRK a
pathway and this is interesting because
nicotinamide driver-side kinase 2 is
actually induced by DNA damage or not
acting in a damage but by various types
of damage like in a damage neuron or a
damaged muscle this pathway is induced
shin MI and others have shown that
nicotinamide to andaman Salvage is very
important in vertebrate cells this
pathway actually declines in aging we
discovered NR as a metabolite and as a
as a vitamin we discovered nicotinic
acid right aside is a metabolite and all
of these additional genes and enzymes in
red green blue a transporter in yeast
and you can see some of the trainees
that did the work this is Katrina bogan
who got her PhD with me this is Peter
belenki who got his PhD with me
and so we discovered you know really a
whole a bunch of new genes and enzymes
and now nicotinamide right aside is
probably considered the most promising
and exciting compound called a stack or
to an activating compound and what you
may know is that resveratrol was once
proposed as sirtuin activating compound
this is a component of red wine there's
work for all at very high doses though
some very interesting things to to mice
has a very complicated mechanism of
action because a resveratrol does a lot
of things including inhibit cyclic AMP e
phosphodiester races and it really does
not have good world bioavailability and
so you know in terms of the
pharmaceutical industry it's really been
a huge financial consumer and and we
think that nicotinamide Ryba side is
really a very exciting compound that l
by l cently elevating nad metabolism it
increases sirtuin activity so this is it
nicotinamide rye beside and the first
our first publication in which we found
it in milk and unlike the discovery of
nicotinic acid then nicotinamide were
assays of kind of malnourished dogs we
didn't harm any animals and the course
of discovering NR and then in three
years later we showed this our to in
activating activity of nicotine why
drive aside so here were extending
lifespan from about twelve and a half
generations to twenty three generations
you abolish that activity if you knock
out the genes that convert NR into nad
this this publication showed that
increasing nad metabolism within our
increases sir to function in a yeast
cell and so NR is kind of special
because it has a unique biosynthetic
pathway it doesn't cause flushing like
nicotinic acid does it doesn't inhibit
sirtuins like nicotinamide does
in our newest paper and I'll kind of
skip to that we show that it is a
favored nad precursor vitamin in the
liver you get more nad from NR than you
do from nicotinic acid or nicotinamide
dose per molar dose and it's also
important because nad declines in aging
and the ability to salvage one of the
endogenous precursors nicotinamide also
is reported to decline in aging and so
part of the interest in supplementing
with NR that we do with with in our
supplements such as those sold by
propels man so the interest in that is
to maintain youthful and optimal nad
metabolism as we age so I think I will
kind of skip forward to show you some of
the things NR does in a metabolically
stressed animal or mice that are on a
high-fat diet if you they're on normal
Chow you section their livers they don't
have a fatty liver if we're on a
high-fat diet these white blobs are
lipid droplets a really hot fatty liver
if you treat these mice with and are
there is much smaller lipid droplets and
these these mice are actually type 2
diabetic on a high-fat diet with n R
they have much smaller lipid droplets as
you can see quantified they have better
liver function they have greatly
improved on non fasting glucose much
better glycemic control and then these
data which were published earlier this
year in scientific reports by Sam
Trammell and and other folks in my lab
show that with obesity and type 2
diabetes there's in
there's terrible diabetic complications
so the the the behavior of these mice
shows that their nerves are shot and
microscopy shows their nerves are shot
and microscopy and behavior shows that
their nerves are protected INR and we're
going to be doing clinical trial with
Michael Abramoff here at the Iowa City
VA and then with Donna Hammond we show
in female rats that we can protect
female rats from chemotherapy-induced
peripheral neuropathy and we can reverse
that and there's a clinical trial plan
there so now here's the here's the thing
said achieve I told you that 12 years
ago
nr was just a plate si does all these
amazing things in in mice and rats I
think I already told you 175,000 or more
people are already taking it yeah it's
an over-the-counter supplement so we
felt like the scientific that we're kind
of getting out over our skis right
because as a natural product companies
like chroma Dex were able to get grass
status of it through the FDA and develop
GMP manufacturing procedures and our and
simply go out there and sell it yeah and
so you know what's the evidence that
it's actually orally available and safe
and a human being has had to start and
and take it and so here's me I was doing
a little home construction renovation
product project at my house and so
somebody had to basically you know be
the first guy or gal to take it and so I
started with an N of one pilot
experiment in which I informed the IRB
at my institution that I that I wanted
to take it and
I wrote out a consent document in which
I said that I understood that there were
probably not very many risks but there
might be a flush reaction or who knows
what and I was informed by the IRB that
if I took it myself it was not
considered human subjects research long
history of n of one trials in which
people take their own stuff but I was
expressly forbidden to give it to anyone
else I'm a department chair so I
certainly couldn't give it to anybody in
my lab or anybody invite my department
but I could take it myself so I started
off doing a pilot experiment where I
took a gram a day for seven days and
sure enough my nad went up in my blood
so essentially nothing happened for the
first four hours and then at just after
four hours my nad went up by about two
point seven fold surprised
another metabolite called NAAG went up
even more 45 fold this was unexpected so
we went into mice I won't go into all of
the data it gets very complicated but we
were able to compare in our nicotinic
acid and nicotinamide in a very defined
time course in mice and and these data
showed that NR boosts liver anyd
metabolism in a mouse to a greater
degree this is in black bear degree than
nicotinic acid which is in blue or
nicotinamide which is in green and with
a different time course and through
unique ne D metabolites and that this
naa D metabolite comes up in mice just
as it does in humans these data also
showed that that NR boosts sirtuin
activity to a much greater degree than
nicotinamide and to a higher degree than
nicotinic acid and then we finally with
at the end of one experiment where
I had shown in my own blood that my nad
metabolism was boosted and then the
mouse in which we found this biomarker
and we cut confirmed the time course and
the dosing of nicotine my drive aside we
went to a properly consented IRB
approved human clinical trial with six
men and six women in which we saw this
nice dose-dependent increase in nad
metabolism multiple metabolites and we
showed with three different doses of it
are 100 MiG's 300 Meg 's and one gram
that single doses of NR give an elevated
nad in the blood 24 hours after taking
it and so this is the citation of what
came out today so we've learned you know
a whole lot in in 12 years that it's a
unique precursor and I won't tell you
everything that we've learned about it
but it's it's in part it's valuable
because of the NRK pathway and the
properties of nrk1 and enter k2 and we
learned in this study that we get more
nad with NR then with the other
precursors there's no flushing there
were no serious adverse events reported
there was a tremendous research activity
with a number of diseases and conditions
in Mises and rats and we're testing
those things in humans and so we're
really excited about in our research and
of course I couldn't have done by myself
and so these are the people in my lab
and and the people that I've
collaborated and the folks that have
given us funding and again I'm happy to
take questions from you or more things
about about our research okay let me see
if anybody has any questions you know I
like I was thinking like this nad ill
that metabolite right
does it get excreted in the
it is just in the black so n/a ad
doesn't done so much get excreted the
stuff that gets excreted into the urine
just phosphate on it okay which you
largely see in the urine our methyl to
py methyl for py uh-huh methylated
nicotinamide and so so NR boosts first
the first thing happens is it goes into
cell gets converted as nmn by nicotine
my driver-side kinase then to nad and
then to nad p right and NADP at ATP h
nadh the interesting biomarker
metabolite nad gets deaminated to na ad
that stays inside the cell and it can
get converted back to nad Plus once nad
gets converted to nicotinamide by for
example a sirtuin then the nicotinamide
can either be salvaged back up to only D
or it can be methylated and excreted
mm-hmm okay
and what is the half-life in the body
basically like you need to take it every
day how does it go so most people that
take an hour supplements true Nyugen for
example take it in the morning to 125
milligrams capsules is quite a lot more
than in a glass of milk it's hundreds of
times more or a thousand times more than
in a glass of milk and of course it
doesn't have any calories because it
doesn't contain the macronutrients that
the calories calorie containing
macronutrients and we know from doing
the clinical work that our nad
metabolism is still higher 24 hours
after
taking an NR supplement the peak nad is
probably about eight hours after after
taking NR some people I know take an
hour a day and have reported improved
sleep by taking an hour both in the
morning and the evening the sleep has
not been clinically tested
you know proven there's an things that
have been observed I would say it's
anecdotal but it's widely observed
report a greater feeling of vitality
more energy now full appearance athletic
performance improved skin some people
say that their hair and fingernails grow
more rapidly I've seen improve digestive
function which is interesting because
he'll Agra has a strong diarrhea
component as you know was observed as a
as a condition of skin dementia as well
as diarrhea in the olden days when there
were populations of people that frankly
didn't have enough nad precursors I have
enough any deeper cursors in my diet to
avoid peligro without taking an R but
when I started taking an R on a daily
basis I observed improve digestion
that's the kind of thing that's going to
be clinically tested as well okay and
you mentioned that nad goes down with
the age right that's been widely
reported so it was first reported in
mice there are some additional reports
of any D declining in human beings as
well yes
so does it help like like we take some
of these things after 50 and all those
like some of the white amines we take
after 50 which is slightly different
than what you don't take and our
so would it be helpful like for the
people who are older this having in the
idea is that we know that that we know
that our metabolism slows in aging we
know that mental function declines in
aging that muscular function declines in
aging and and and interestingly you know
nad is central to all of those processes
any declines in aging and so it's
thought that by boosting any D
metabolism with a non flushing non
sirtuin inhibiting any the precursor
vitamin and NR is really the only thing
that we know of that that won't that
will increase any D without causing
flushing and without inhibiting sirtuins
we think that by boosting an ad
metabolism that we can potentially age
better and so that's absolutely the idea
of course at this time NR is being
marketed as an over-the-counter
supplement so it's not intended to treat
any disease or condition and you know
your mileage may vary but it's
absolutely something that can be tried
and so people keep a journal and but
it's going to be very important as we do
more clinical testing that placebo
controlled in order to really test
conclusively whether NR has some of the
activities in a human being that it has
in a mouse and a rat because frankly in
a mouse in a rat the more metabolically
dysregulated the mouse is the worst the
diet that the mouse has and the older
the mouse is the more profound the
effects of NR has so in a healthy Mouse
it's hard to see the effect of NR in a
red mouse or a mouse with hearing loss
a mouse that spit were a rat that's been
treated with chemotherapy the effects of
nicotine my driver-side are profound
there you go I one other thing if I made
about clinical testing yeah some there
are some nutritional supplements like
selenium are that have profound effects
but have been difficult to detect the
beneficial effects of selenium even
though they would have been anticipated
from preclinical work and and the
thinking is that when selenium got to do
clinical testing the people that were
interested in participating may have
wanted selenium so they may have gone to
GNC or Whole Foods or whatever and
gotten selenium and so effectively
everyone on trial experimental group as
well as the supposed placebo group may
have been taking selenium ah I've got a
solution to this problem the biomarker
nad itself is a pretty abundant
metabolite it's just like testosterone
everyone every male has a level of
testosterone
you can tell who's juicing right who's
taking a testosterone supplement when
you do targeted men a speck on the
androgen metabolomic for low abundance
metabolites right that way they can see
the specific metabolites that a person
might be taking and other metabolites
that get that are normally at a low
level that get to be at a much higher
level when a person takes those kinds of
supplements well we discovered that naa
D is normally below the detection limit
in a person that's not supplementing and
it goes up to almost 1 micromolar in a
person that has taken NR so by using the
information that we just published today
in Nature communications we'll be able
to MA
or clinical testing and being able to
observe not only increases in nad
metabolism but will actually be able to
exclude any participants that are
supposed to be in the placebo group yeah
what are actually cheating and are
taking an honor and do you have any
allies that test out anything further
nad allies that kind of thing so that's
a that's a great question so the way
that we measure the nad metabolism s
it's right which means that you almost
have to be in my lab and I will have a
lot of specialized equipment and
extraction and everything and so you're
pointing out do we have a cheap
inexpensive way on like a kit yeah we're
detecting nad and that's actually part
of the reason that I established the
company and our omics
mm-hmm develop those kinds of kits and
and tools that we could commercialize
and disseminate that would allow people
to measure increases in anyd metabolism
as well as decrements and deficiencies
and anything metabolism without the
complicated machinery and facilities
that you require from aspects so short
answer is no I don't have a kit for nad
or for boosted or for decremented nad
metabolism but we're very much
interested in and the other question is
like you mentioned about the sleep and
all so is there any work planned
regarding circadian rhythm yeah yeah so
it's a great great question so um
nad metabolism like many other things is
highly regulated by circadian cycles and
so when the mouse
nad metabolism Peaks at night which is
when mice are active and they're eating
mm-hmm that's why people that are
supplementing supplement when they get
up right so it's a this is another
important point is that
although there's NR in milk uh the real
most important sources of nad metabolism
are actually in food I like to say Whole
Foods with a small W in a small F so
when you we eat cellular stuff whether
it's meat vegetables grains we're
breaking down cells and when we break
down cells there are abundant
metabolites like nad and a B pH that
broke get broken down into non
phosphorylated compounds including NR
nicotinamide nicotinic acid that JIT
then get taken up by cells and get
converted back into nad so while milk is
kind of unique in that it's nad
metabolomic has not include any cellular
metabolites because it's not a cellular
material
it's an extracellular material so the
nad metabolomic milk consists of an NR
and nicotinamide we published that in
the Journal of nutrition earlier this
year I was actually trammel 16 a 20 the
the the diabetic neuropathy stand was
trammel 16b yeah and today's paper
terminal 16 C but milk is unique in that
it has NR other foods contain
essentially get broken down but we don't
have control over the degree to which
food gets broken down into NR or
nicotine matter or nicotinic acid which
are sort of less valuable many
precursors and that's why
supplementation makes some sense
especially as we age okay and the last
question is regarding the chemotherapy
yeah so you mentioned like there is a
paper published it helps with the people
with the chemotherapy
yeah published so there's there's work
that that and has been prevent presented
at meetings and
in abstracts and in grant proposals in
which and this is a collaboration with
Donna Hammond Marta Hamma Hamma T PhD in
professor Donna Hammonds lab in which
we've tested rats for their resistance
to chemotherapy unique neuropathy and
attended my driver-side has has strong
activity in that assay and on the basis
of the very exciting preclinical data
that the Hammond group and and our group
demonstrated we have been funded to do a
Phase two clinical study of women
undergoing cancer chemotherapy with
black pepper attack so the CNR will
allow them to complete chemotherapy on
pep attack so so we are excited by the
possibility that in our prevents the
therapeutic neuropathy in beings but
that's not yet been demonstrated and in
a rack that okay yeah that would be
interesting because I have heard a lot
of people having that the neuropathic
problem with the chemotherapy so the
effective works of if it works out that
would be very good discovery and
definitely you can add one more feather
to your cap well you know it's it's a
great story and it relates to the fact
that nad is degraded in the course of
neurodegeneration and part of our group
is engaged in work to try to understand
the mechanism by which any D is degraded
generation and the mechanism by which NR
protects and you know some people think
that it relates entirely too sir to in
activities we think that sirtuins are
important but we think that resistance
to reactive oxygen species damage is
also very important and that by boosting
da-ad metal element including NADPH in
liver in a damaged neuron and and many
other tissues that NR is protective
okay I think we're almost out of time
it's been one hour thank you very much
for taking your time precious time and
come and talk to us and I think the
viewer must be really delighted and we
have I think I don't know if they're
from your lab there are a few viewers
today so which is very interesting thank
thank you so much so I would like to
again talk to you when you are the next
nature communication paper comes out
great great thanks thanks and thanks to
all the people that had watched you can
find our lab at Brenner I think it's
biochem dot you Iowa dot edu slash
Brenner and and people can email you
right if they're interested yeah okay
okay thanks a lot
here